[Music]
hello plastic pills listeners
we're here with a very special guest and
friend of the channel ben burgess who is
the author of
give them an argument uh and most
recently canceling comedians while the
world burns
a critique of the contemporary left uh
make sure you check that out with zero
books
so today we're here to talk about
liberty uh and in particular
libertarianism uh and rather than just
spending an hour to
sitting there dunking on our favorite
bad libertarian arguments we decided to
actually go for the gold standard
by talking about a little book uh by
jason brennan
which is essentially intended as an
introduction to the libertarian
tradition
and what i think is very interesting
about this book is
unlike a lot of the bulimics out there
he actually describes it as
kind of an olive branch to those who
don't actually
like libertarianism all that much in the
intro he talks a little bit about
how he has this democratic aunt who is
hostile to
everything she thinks libertarianism is
about and the book is in some ways
a manual for her it's called
libertarianism
what everyone needs to know so there's a
lot of different arguments that are put
forward in this book
and we'll probably get into the weeds
with a lot of them but before
we dive into that i was just thinking um
i wanted to hear what you guys have to
say so ben
what are your thoughts i know you're a
huge brandon fan
yeah i mean to put my cards on the table
here
um you know brennan is somebody
who i probably first encountered yeah
i might have first seen him when he was
writing for bleeding heart libertarians
um which i mean he might still do but
you know it's been a long time so i
looked at that
uh blog uh but uh i
i really i think first started to be
aware of who he was
uh when he was writing a bunch of stuff
basically
um opposing the drive to organize
adjuncts to uh you know so
they get paid a living wage and get
health insurance and all that stuff and
uh as somebody who
was in exactly that position at the time
uh that's uh that that
you know uh you know he earned a eternal
place on my [ __ ] list you know uh
because of uh
uh because of that you know as as like
you know sort of this this cartoonish
figure of uh of a very comfortable
tenured professor
uh who is uh who's opposed to uh to
efforts to get a more just deal for
adjuncts
and would make sort of specious
arguments about how there are other
things that you could do for them with
the money and blah blah blah
but i mean i do so that said right i
mean i i do really just
you know i mean i i feel great dislike
for him in my heart in my heart as a
human being
uh because of that uh and also
you know some of the other stuff that
i've read by him you know i've often
found a lot of the ways that he argues
to be to be very smug and very glib
you know as far as characterizing like
lefty arguments that he's opposed to
and you know none of that makes me feel
any more warmly towards him
that said uh i i do
think that in some ways like this is
like grading on a curve with libertarian
books i mean this this this is actually
uh this is actually kind of okay in some
ways like like like brennan is the sort
of person
who i i would most like to engage
with on these issues because um
even though i mean i will say right at
the outset i found a lot of the
consequentialist economic arguments
uh that uh that he uh that he makes in
this book
uh you know like pretty rushed and and a
little sloppy and you know and and
uh way too a priori uh
but uh he's also like
a philosophically sophisticated defender
of libertarianism
who is uh who's alive to at least
some of the problems and ambiguities
about the things that he wants to argue
for
and he's certainly steeped in like my
preferred
you know my preferred way of of of doing
philosophy and presenting his arguments
you know so
and and you know and and he's also like
a pretty smooth writer i mean this is
this is a pretty quick read so you know
and
like considering like all of my biases
against you know
against brennan like i'm not too angry
about having had to read this book
yeah one of the things that i like about
the text and i do like the text as an
expository piece
um is that it is pitched uh at
surprisingly high um level of aesthetic
uh readability right
you can disagree with the arguments but
you're never going to be sitting there
wondering
what exactly he's trying to argue at any
given time which you sometimes feel when
you're reading you know the jock
narratives of the world
or whatever right i think it's kind of
worth saying that
like the fact that it's an introductory
text and the way it's organized i think
both helped
and hurt the book to some extent because
i and and it's worth mentioning for the
audience too because i don't think we
were clear i think the
the book is written in this unique way
which is actually a series from oxford
university press called like
what everyone needs to know and like if
you go to the oxford website you can
find a bunch of other ones that aren't
on philosophical topics like there's one
about like
whatever medical science and pandemics
and like you know india and it'll be
like what everyone needs to know like a
really broad topic of like a broad range
of academic topics
and this one just happens to be the
libertarianism one and the way it's
written right is like
um along these uh over just over 100
questions so like you know you'll get
like
what is libertarianism are libertarians
liberals
um is libertarianism a radical view
right and then like it's organized by
chapters so like you'll have
chapters about human nature and ethics
right like do libertarians believe that
uh
everyone should be selfish um and then
like
questions about democracy and civil
rights and i think uh you get the point
and i think that that's like really good
for um
for kind of like going through the book
and i think brennan even says at the
beginning of the book that he
it's purposely written in such a way
that you don't actually have to read the
whole thing right so he's like you can
go
and if you're just curious about one of
those questions you know you can just go
and have a look and see what he has to
say about it
and i think he does do a good job of
knocking down a lot of like the really
cringy libertarianism
arguments right like you know a few
times reading the book it made me think
of um i think someone that both ben and
matt debated that stefan mullin you and
i was like stef von mal mullen you would
actually probably do
pretty well to read this book and see
like that his cringy take on on
libertarianism is
really unsophisticated and like bad i
think
i guess it would fall under what what
brennan calls hard libertarianism
uh as opposed to um you know a classical
liberalism and then i think he calls
himself like a neo-classical liberal
which is kind of interesting maybe we'll
talk
a little bit more about that later um
but i think like one of the things that
was a little bit disappointing reading
the book was that
was like some of the more media issues
the parts that i wanted to see like
a more robust defense so for example um
you know he talks a few times about like
do why do libertarianism do libertarians
oppose the welfare state or what do they
think about economic inequality
and he says some things that hopefully
we'll get into talking in in detail
about but
i think because of the format of the
book like his defenses of those things
because they ended up being limited to
like a few paragraphs
or like even or maybe at best like maybe
five
six pages so it was like he would say
things and kind of defend them but then
i would just be disappointed because i
really wanted
a steel man even though i am like ben
and matt probably somewhat hostile
towards libertarianism
i've encountered a lot of libertarians
who will say things like under ideal
conditions you would never have crony
capitalism because the market isn't
supposed to work this way
and my response is they actually sound
like a lot of tankies i know who will
say things like
well it wasn't real communism isn't
supposed to look this way in practice it
was going to be very different
we'll get it right at one point uh and
this is why i say to both stalinists
and the libertarians that we need to be
good dialecticians
and recognize that no this is actually
what it looks like when you have
unbridled capitalism
naturally firms are going to use their
market power
to try to influence the state to pass
policies that are beneficial to them
there's simply no historical evidence i
can see
that can testify to a point where they
haven't done that right
any situation i can think of that's what
large enough firms will try to do for
obvious economic reasons
right so this idea that we can have
something like a truly free market under
capitalist conditions
that conforms to the libertarian
paradise just seems to me like
a historical impossibility at least if
we look at the case studies going
forward
and while i'm absolutely willing to say
that government bears some
responsibility for that
of course it takes two to tango and one
of the things that's frustrating is that
they'll of course
never look at the market side of things
uh when it comes to crony capitalism
uh this is true of prageru also that
released a video on
crony capitalism it's always the state's
fault right uh
never you know these large firms one of
the things i wanted to say about bretton
that's interesting is
twofold right uh one is that sometimes
he is willing to be far more consistent
uh on certain points than many other
online libertarians as ben would put it
that we know on the immigration issue he
says look you know
if you're opposed to state intervention
in the lives of people that means you
can't have something like a strong
border
in fact you might not be able to have
any border at all right uh since
interference with people's mobility
rights whether they're american mexican
canadian
uh martian you know you name it right so
i do appreciate that right that he's
willing to kind of
bite the bullet in that respect uh
sometimes that leads to positions though
that
many people on the left will be very
hostile to uh
and i have a begrudging respect for him
for being willing to bite those
bullets as well since i think even a lot
of conventional liberals wouldn't want
um
want that and a very good example that
isn't present in this book but actually
in his text against democracy where
rather like hayek of yore he says
look why do you presuppose that a
liberal society would need to be
democratic
in some way shape or form right maybe we
could actually do better than democracy
which is also something that comes up in
the book
but before we kind of delve into the
weeds here i just figured we should
talk about this uh particular section
since i think this is really at the
heart of the book
uh so in the first of these kind of
numbered sections uh he says
libertarianism is a political philosophy
which is in itself is telling uh it's
not an
economic outlook he defines it as a
political philosophy
but in terms of what they advocate he
says and i think many of us will take
issue with this
uh libertarians advocate and this is
italicized radical tolerance
uh libertarianism is a demanding
doctrine it demands that we mind our own
business
even though most of us would rather not
in a free society
quote unquote some of us will choose to
follow traditional lifestyles other will
choose
new ways of living some will choose
tight-knit communities some will choose
communes some will choose a life alone
some will be wicked some will be
virtuous so long as a person lives in
peace and respects others liberty
she may live her life as she chooses
libertarians say
live and let live as paul mccartney
would put it so
i think that's a good kind of jumping
off star a point for our broader
discussion about these themes
i personally think that there's deep
problems with this
particularly in this kind of
propertarian
elements since i'm not really sure you
can have a tolerant society and have
propertarianism but
before i dive into that what do you guys
think yeah i mean i i do just want to
say
uh like i agree with you right it's it's
to his credit that he's
he's consistent on the immigration issue
although that is one place where he's
um there is like one of his habits in
writing this that like
did annoy me a little bit that came up
which is uh
his tendency to um
either attribute his views to
libertarians with no qualifiers
or attribute his views to many
libertarians
uh you know and not really
admit you know that there are many
prominent libertarians who who disagree
right so um he mentions like ron paul uh
you know several times over the course
of the book as as evidence of the
growing popularity of libertarianism
i don't know exactly when this book was
written and knows during the obama
administration
uh so probably the um you know ron
paul's 2012 you know run for uh for
president
uh you know is is a uh i think my sense
is that that was something that
happened recently you know when uh when
this is written but you know he mentions
paul
to show the popularity of libertarianism
several times but you know ron paul
uh is extremely anti-immigration
uh like like to the point of advocating
uh the
uh the like i've been to the
constitution and get rid of rid of
birthright citizenship
uh so so that you can't have so-called
anchor babies uh
in uh you know in the us coming you know
when their you know parents come over
you know as undocumented immigrants
uh from uh from mexico or marie rothbard
who i think is somebody he mentions in
there you know had a
uh you know is a extremely prominent
libertarian thinker who uh who had
anti-immigration uh views and had this
racist let's just be clear yeah by the
end
for sure right like i mean you know
rothbard in a lot of ways was like a
you know smarter and he's a better
writer but i mean a lot of ways he's
sort of a proto-molyneux
um and uh and and yeah rothbard had
yeah these very molonu-esque uh sort of
explanations of why it was actually okay
uh to uh to to restrict immigration and
uh how
maybe even libertarian principles meant
you should restrict immigration because
uh because you know because taxpayers
uh you know own the state in some sense
so it's like really their private
property rights that you know they can't
have people
come trespass in which is you know which
is a very tortured explanation and i
think to give brennan credit where
credit's due i think like
put you know murray rothbard or ron paul
or steph and molina in a room with jason
brennan
and to argue about immigration and i
don't doubt that like brennan would like
tear all of their rationalizations to
shreds uh
but also it just seemed like yeah i
don't know like especially because in
some places he'll acknowledge the
existence of intra-libertarian
differences but then like
in other places he he really doesn't
want to or like another one that really
bothered me along the same lines
that i know i mentioned to you guys uh
messages before this was about
civil rights uh that he he says that you
know he brings up
civil rights and uh you know jim crow
and all that stuff
uh you know several times you know
through pratha
throughout the book uh and
then like he never quite like
grapples with the fact that there is
this like super obvious
libertarian objection to civil rights
legislation that like was actually
like is the reason for example that ron
paul's son rand paul
uh said uh told rachel maddow infamously
when he was running for uh for senate
the first time that he would have voted
against the civil rights act of 1964
because it told private business owners
you know what what they could do with
their own property
you know uh and there's a there's a sort
of weird passage where
uh brennan kind of grapples with the
issue
and he sort of says well from a
libertarian perspective there's at least
this prima facie
uh you know right to do it with you know
to to engage in private discrimination
but you know here's a problem so maybe
private discrimination can't be allowed
which is great but it's like also
it's like i don't know if you're gonna
do like the introduction libertarianism
you might as well you should at least
admit that hard libertarians
uh disagree with you uh about this uh
and in fact some not very hard
libertarians
like rand paul disagree with you about
that and some like
people who are like quasi conservative
like you know people who are
very influential in the libertarian
movement like barry goldwater you know
disagreed with you about this and so
uh so all of which is just to say that
like a lot of times it seems to me that
he's he's attributing his
he um that like anything that sort of
makes libertarians
sound good to liberals uh he'll he'll
sort of attribute
that version of libertarianism to
libertarianism in general
without doing the thing that i think
would have been a little bit more
intellectually honest and awkward which
is
uh which is acknowledging uh that lots
of libertarians have
found libertarian reasons to be on the
wrong side of these issues and like
especially
like in that civil rights case i mean
yeah it's to his credit that is a
neoclassical liberal or whatever he
wants to call himself you know he's
willing to
accept that non-libertarian reasons
overwhelm his libertarian principles in
this case but
also it seemed a little bit awkward and
like mumbly
you know that he's like not quite coming
to grips with the fact that he's he has
very unlibertarian reasons
for uh for for taking that that position
it's not the libertarian principles
are telling him you know to uh to
support uh mandatory integration laws
you know
it's that he's willing to let
libertarianism
uh you know let the libertarianism take
a hit so that's so so that's that's just
one thing that bothered me yeah i had
many of the same difficulties as you
um i mean one of the things that i think
aged particularly poorly in the book uh
just empirically was
uh he cites the tea party movement
charitably uh as kind of a
proto-libertarian movement
that we should keep an eye on since
they're advancing many ideas that he
likes
uh and then you know circa 2016 when
he's complaining about trump uh a lot of
that
seems to disappear uh without so much as
a word right and uh
many of us who are a little bit more
critical of the american political right
might have said well
did you really think the tea party
movement was going to wind up becoming a
bastion of libertarian thought and
advocacy for personal freedom and open
borders might have been a little bit
naive there uh but also the more
fundamental point
uh i do think like you said it's a
well-written book uh i definitely think
he's trying to polish the libertarian
tradition
up uh to make it more palatable as he
says to people who might be skeptical of
it like his democratic aunt
and that's all well and good right we
all engage in bulimics
and dogmatics to try to advocate for our
positions but at certain points i think
there's actually
a pretty brazen tension in his work uh
where he does underplay
too much uh some of the uglier sides of
libertarian doctrine
one that particularly offended me is uh
in the very first paragraph he talks
about how
libertarians are for a kind of radical
equality
um liberal radical equality as it were
and his argument for that which fair
enough is that look nobody should be
allowed to impose their vision of the
good life upon you
everyone's vision of the id life should
be uh considered equally according to
law
uh even if they're not necessarily equal
in themselves or
equal in terms of their virtue and
you're fair enough right except that
there are a long line of libertarian
thinkers going back to ludwig von mises
or at least
libertarian um proto-libertarian
thinkers
uh who've always insisted fundamentally
on the inequality
of human beings uh you know von misa and
iran had this famous exchange where
uh mises said you know you have you know
the audacity or the bravery i can't
remember exactly the term
uh to tell the masses but no one else
wants to tell them which is that you're
inferior
right and all the benefits uh that
you've accrued
you owe to men who are better than you
right um
and you know you see brand make
reference to that all the time you know
with their
uh description of people as parasites or
second-handers
uh relative to you know the few creative
individuals in a capitalist society
who've actually
done everything right and i do wish he
had spent quite a bit more time
engaging with this much uglier side uh
much less egalitarian side to
libertarianism
particularly since post 2012
when he wrote the book uh we've seen a
lot more of that come to the fore
in online spaces where it's almost
become kind of a joke where if somebody
says they're a libertarian
your media thought process would go oh
are you a libertarian are you actually
just an alt-right kind of personality
who doesn't like woke people
uh as far as using this as a convenient
label i don't know what you guys think
both of you i think are identifying like
this sort of tension
in in what what is like the normative
motivation for brennan i guess so like
like i think it's what's interesting to
me is right like the position he
ascribes to himself
neoclassical liberal he says it's uh it
shares many of the same things as
classical liberalism but what separates
it is that it's
has an explicit foundational concern
with social justice right which he
defines
as concerns with distributive justice uh
like so allah rolls um right so like how
do we make sure that that people have
opportunities to
to to like fulfill their to work with
their um
the necessary conditions to express
their freedom and live a good life
so i think like what's interesting is it
seems
like there's like he is kind of leaning
on
classic libertarian normative motivation
which is just this explicit concern with
like liberty right and not being
interfered with
but then social justice is more of like
a consequentialist concern
so like it just seems like uh the
neoclassical position he's working with
has a when it's convenient like he'll
he'll
he'll lean on like the libertarian uh
the more like i guess
um pure or hard libertarian reason but
then in other in other circumstances
he'll talk about uh
you know the need for social
institutions that are gonna benefit uh
the most number of people right and
and so he'll he'll use um
you know i think the example of of uh
open borders right is something like
the main thing is the concern with
social justice um and like distributive
justice right so
i mean it was just i guess strange
that like that that that that tension
seemed to come up
depending on on what kind of topic he
was
he was looking at and i guess i'm
curious if what you guys thought about
that
yeah and so that that is that is
extremely interesting
like there were lots of passages uh
where he he does suggest some you know
even though he says he's not a hard
libertarian
which at the very least means that he
doesn't believe in
uh absolute property rights you know
that can't give way to uh to anything
else
uh any competing considerations or any
circumstances
uh but there are all these passages
where he
he does sound like a hard-ish uh
libertarian you know he'll
he'll say he'll say things like oh look
at all these rights that people have
that can't be sacrificed
for these other goals and he'll list off
the other goals and he'll even include
like economic
efficiency as one of those goals that
you know that people's rights can't be
sacrificed for but in then in other
passages
uh he he says uh he has this like fairly
consequentialist way of understanding
like what property rights even are in
the first place that you know that they
have that
they arise out of social conventions and
you know people don't have a reason to
accept those conventions
if they're not going to benefit you know
enough in in the uh in the long term
from them
uh so so i think there i think there is
um
i think there's for sure uh some some
some tension there
i mean i think that the stuff that
matt's talking about about
you know like leaving people free to to
pursue their conception of the good life
uh does
get it one of the things that i found
most frustrating about it which also
goes to what you're saying victor
because um like the thing about
you know consequentialist arguments is
that they're actually much harder to
make
than than like in principle or
deontological arguments right you know
you can sort of say
like you can you can kind of give a pair
an argument in a couple paragraphs that
you know
something would violate the categorical
imperative or the non-aggression
principle or whatever and like
that actually might be an okay argument
whereas uh consequentialist arguments
are four reasons that brennan himself
gestures at at some points in the text
uh incredibly more difficult because uh
you don't just like to make a serious
consequentialist argument for something
it's not good enough to just sort of
um look at okay one sort of respect in
which it might play out you know in
terms of like one factor
because you know because decisions
always have all kinds of intended and
unintended you know consequences which
he emphasizes where that's convenient
but then his
uh then his cons but his
consequentialist arguments were always
so
simplistic they they tend to just be
very like you know not incorporate very
many dimensions of how things might play
out
and he doesn't even really seem to
consider you know a lot of the
consequentialist arguments that might
take someone from
his goals to very non-libertarian
conclusions so
uh like an obvious one and maybe this
goes back to matt's point about how
this was written several years back and
you know
like in a very different political
landscape in some ways and so
if i could just pause you there ben
because i think it is important to
situate this in context uh
one of the things that he foregrounds in
this book that maybe isn't as
politically relevant today
that i definitely think is an olive
branch to the political left uh is his
concern for international peace
and he's quite implicitly scathing
towards the bush administration
for mobilizing conservative support for
the war in iraq
and the war in afghanistan which he
thinks is fundamentally wrong and he
does try
to kind of coax you into buying into
this uh sometimes convincingly i think
by saying look
a genuine libertarianism uh would never
support something like these kinds of
interventions
right it's a very very different world
than our 2016 post-trunk covered kind of
universe
it seems like forever ago yeah
absolutely right i mean like
as you said the tea party was the thing
back then uh and and it's it's really
like become a distant memory now uh i
would argue because it was always just a
branding exercise like i think actually
um one of the most perceptive you know
not somebody who's politics or my
politics but you know one of the most
perceptive comments about this i
remember was actually
jon stewart on the daily show when he
was uh interviewing ron paul and he said
look you're the real thing as far as the
tea party goes
most tea partiers are just uh are just
the memorial majority in the tri-corner
hat
uh you know which which is exactly right
uh that it was always just sort of a
branding exercise for basic
conservativism
uh whereas brennan thought that it
really showed you know this the sort of
popularity of libertarian principles
but also and this is something i was
kind of reminding myself of
like several times during while i was
reading it uh he was writing it
before that first bernie sanders
campaign and and
uh and the rise of uh
you know of of dsa and the squad and
congress
and and all of that stuff right which i
think does make a difference because
i do think to be fair to brennan that
there are things that if he had written
it today he probably would have grappled
with
that you know he maybe didn't need to
because they just weren't
as much on on people's minds and
political discussions in 2013 or
whatever this was
uh and but like i think a couple of
those like really do
like show how like yeah there are some
like pretty obvious ways you can make
consequentialist arguments given his
stated goals
for very anti-libertarian conclusions do
you want to give everybody a chance to
pursue the good life well
uh are people more or less likely to
quit their job to uh to spend a year
you know living on a tighter budget and
finally writing that novel
uh if they don't have to worry that
losing their job means they don't have
health insurance
are are people more or less likely to go
to school and you know get the training
that they need
for a new career uh if uh if college is
uh is tuition free and you know paid for
by progressive
you know taxation you know etc right
like there are all sorts of obvious ways
that you can get from everybody should
be able to pursue the you know the good
life as they wish
uh to uh to very to very non-libertarian
uh conclusions about economics uh and
especially because
brennan himself i mean this this
whatever sort of
yeah i i agree it's like an under
theorized thing in the book like
at least in this book you know exactly
how neoclassical liberalism is supposed
to be different from from hard
libertarianism
but it does seem relatively clear that
one way it's supposed to be different
is that he is kind of acknowledging even
though he kind of wants to have it both
ways at certain points of the book
that property rights are not like are
not like bodily autonomy rights that you
know that that redistributing money
really is not
like redistributing sexual partners or
whatever you know that they
and and once you've admitted that then
if you still want to end up in
libertarian places your your
consequentialist arguments better be
airtight and and i just didn't think
they were
yeah i think doesn't he say um at one
point
that uh his view is a presumption of
liberty as opposed to
a uh like like as opposed to like
i don't know uh some sort of sanctity of
lib of liberty that it's like something
that cannot be violated yeah that's
right i think he has a
a question where it's like you know what
when is when can liberty or can liberty
be violated for libertarians right and
he says
it's a it's a prima facie presumption
that liberty is is the goal
but there's always going to be
circumstances right where that can be
um that can maybe be uh contradicted and
specifically right his normative
motivation is like what he calls
social justice so i guess he thinks i
mean i think
he's what he's trying to do is like show
that
that the best way to achieve social
justice right is obviously through these
libertarian means that that respect
freedom and
and free and and uh like free economic
activity
you know but i think one of the one of
the examples right when he's making
these sort of consequentialist arguments
for why like liberty and open markets
i mean they seem to stand and fall on
just like empirical claims right like
there's a bunch of chapters
uh one where he talks about that i found
particularly unconvincing at least
was like you know our libertarians
trying to protect big business
and he says something he makes this
empirical claim right um
by what seemed like cherry picked
examples but again
as i said at the beginning because a lot
of his answers to these questions were
kind of brief it's like he didn't give a
very robust defense he just kind of
would say so like he would say you know
actually like
more government power is what leads to
more corporate power right he has this
whole thing where he keeps on
like kind of harping on this point that
if you look
through the history you can see that
like government power
just ends up picking and choosing
corporate winners right and like that's
actually the thing that leads to crony
capitalism is like government
and i mean it just kind of depends on on
the empirical claim and i found myself
thinking that that's true that that's
happened sometimes
like clearly government and decides to
subsidize
corn crops and and uh he talks about
that
big arthur daniels midland i think is
the company that he brings up a few
times
that they have protected so it's true
but it just seemed very like a like a
very weak
argument because it's like he's picking
examples that has happened i agree i
think most
leftists are also agree that that's a
bad thing when that happens
but to say for but to but to generalize
from that and say
well because it's happened in these
cases that means government in principle
leads to more corporate power seemed
like a stretch
to me it's not even just that it's the
state's fault uh
it's that like this solution
is really unclear at least to me right
you know he says
well the way this basically the way to
stop you know corporations from buying
politicians
is to have you know like a really
minimal libertarian state so there's
nothing to buy
is like okay but like
you know what's what's the game plan
here right like
how how is it that you're going to
continue to have these extreme
concentrations of wealth
but also not have uh not have the people
the wealthy people um you know use that
influence you know politically to uh to
get themselves you know to get
themselves special favors i mean like
it just seems it just seems like well we
just have to go through some period
where everybody's virtuously abstaining
from that
and uh and this is something i would
also argue like really
undermines what he says in uh chapter
seven when
uh when he he argues that uh well
there's really no reason to be an
egalitarian
uh you know that like the that anything
that looks like the sort of moral force
of egalitarianism is captured by like a
few other considerations like welfarism
you know that like
as long as the people at the bottom have
enough you know them like this there's
no
you know like there's no remaining
reason to you know to care
about um about inequality
uh but this this is a reason right that
if there's wildly unequal distribution
of economic resources there's gonna be a
wildly unequal distribution of political
influence uh and so yeah i agree i mean
i think it's a very
like um i i i actually
think in like much the same way that the
tankies think that you can have
a uh a state that doesn't have like
legal protections of you know individual
rights whatever but it's not gonna
you know you're not gonna get these
these these horrors um
you know i i think believing that you
can have like dramatic inequality
without um you know with without the
people the uh
at the top you know calling in favors
from the state just just seems
uh just seems extremely naive not to
mention of course that the sort of
traditional socialist argument which is
that um
that the same process is gonna play out
at the uh at the workplace that if you
have uh that if
um that if some people have they have
way more than others
uh then then some people are going to be
in a position
a bargaining position to get other
people to uh to to submit to their will
you know as as bosses you know as bosses
in the workplace and
neither of those reasons to to care
about inequality are really things that
he
that he grapples with at all in the book
i don't even think he mentions
uh like or addresses monopolies i was
kind of waiting for him to try to talk
to like say something i mean unless i
missed it but i don't remember him at
all being
saying that there was some like like
intrinsic
uh reason related to libertarian moral
arguments that would
like prevent i guess just like more
competition but i mean i don't know
empirically that just seems
really uh really unconvincing and i will
also say like that like when he's
the extent which he addresses it you
know is like you say he just keeps on
saying well
uh you know it's because like government
action you know help it helps
you know big businesses consolidate or
provides incentives you know for big
business consolidation
uh but i also think it's like really
telling about the limits of his
uh of his concern here because uh like
there's no
the whole thing is like from a
perspective that assumes that like
really the objection
to libertarianism just serving the
interests of business
is that it would serve the interests of
big business
uh that you know that that like the pers
the people who
like sure let's say for the sake of
argument libertarian
you know libertarian uh policies would
result in
much less consolidated you know
enterprises that you'd have
that like ownership would be much more
much more dispersed well you know that's
that's that's good news for small
business owners but it's not at all
obvious uh that that helps uh that helps
workers much i mean if anything you know
wages tend to be
tend to be lower at smaller businesses
yeah absolutely i mean one of the
historical arguments that i typically
make
with regard to this crony capitalism
point is that uh we've never seen a
libertarian paradise
uh but we have seen plutocracy for you
know three or four thousand years at
this point right so it's a much more
recognizable form of government
uh than anything that they're putting
forward yeah and
he says like things like oh like when
he's
arguing that like left-wing policies are
gonna make the problem worse
uh and lead to more corporate
consolidation he says well the moderate
left and the shape the democratic party
has been in power but that he never
seems to do the parallel thing and say
like well hold on so are haven't
libertarian preferences
uh been at least as much implemented you
know through uh through
uh you know like deficit hawk
conservatives you know as uh
as as certainly as as you can say like
any kind of robust
left-wing preferences have been through
moderate democrats i mean like the uh
like you know ronald reagan uh you know
when he was running for president gave
interviews to reason magazine where he
said you know uh
libertarianism is the core of
conservativism and of course
you know somebody as smart as brennan
could list off like spend a couple pages
listing off all the
all the respects in which that's
[ __ ] as far as like
uh reagan's you know reagan's policies
and uh and you know conservativism
in general but like also you know there
are no past democratic presidents who
said that the core of liberalism was
socialism
yeah very true well i i want to move on
briefly to the kind of deontological
dimensions of this argument since i
think that's what a lot of us want to
bite our teeth into
since as ben mentioned the kind of
consequentialist arguments he makes
about economic efficiency we could be
here all day going back and forth with
examples on that uh maybe we will in a
sequel episode
but a lot of the stuff that he says uh
at the opening of the book uh
as a kind of set of axioms that
libertarians take to be true or at least
presumed to be true to use victor's
language
might actually sound very attractive to
people on the political left uh i'll
just run through them for
very quickly right radical respect
radical equality
radical peace uh responsibility not
radical responsibility strangely
and then finally radical freedom uh i
mean it's almost
strange how often that word is invoked
since you can go through anything by
a contemporary socialist and they won't
use the term radical
as often as that you know victor and i
kind of joke around about that every now
and then
but you know look my argument is in
principle i'm willing to grant him
uh this kind of axiomatic preference for
moral equality
and individual freedom we can argue
about that from a meta ethical
standpoint and if we want to get really
into the weeds that would be extremely
important
but let's just give him that for right
now the question that i would have is
would be is a libertarian system of the
site the type he describes
the best system for securing individual
liberty
uh and moral equality and my contention
would be that it's not
uh and the contention that i would make
about this is that
almost any socialist uh particularly you
know 21st century
is going to have an extreme degree of
respect at least for bodily autonomy
and ben you and i talked about that a
little bit last week right uh you know
most socialists and leftists today will
think
it's very important for instance that
women have a right to choose uh whether
or not to have an abortion
uh most of us are anti-war on drugs uh
most of us tend to be
put a lot of weight on the importance of
mobility rights particularly for
migrants
right so we would all agree with brennan
on this one uh i think the disagreement
would come
uh on the possessive individualist point
uh this idea that what's important to
freedom and equality isn't just bodily
autonomy
but property rights uh what's
interesting is he shifts gears later in
the book when defending property rights
from the kind of deontological language
he uses earlier in the text
to a much more consequentialist kind of
perspective uh
which isn't what you see some people
like nozick do you know where he says
look you know we want property rights
because they
enhance economic efficiency it looks
after the poor and i think that one of
the reasons for this
shift in orientation is precisely
because brennan knows that
it's very difficult as ben said to move
from this notion of individual freedom
moral equality and
as it relates to bodily autonomy to a
very strict concept
of property rights try though many
libertarians have
right yeah uh
and and i think uh again it's especially
hard to shift
uh to to shift to that yeah i mean
because of course
right like we were talking about uh last
week uh
if if you try to run like the the nozick
you know kind of argument which uh by
the way i'm still
like every time i think back to what you
mentioned that that still makes me laugh
that like
uh that that nozick uh buried the um
uh the sort of like big obvious
objection to his to his defense
of of existing property rights in a
footnote uh that that that's when credit
where credits do at least he was aware
that it was an objection
right fair enough but like the book
several hundred pages long it all seems
to be defending one thing and then you
say well
actually none of this quite applies to
the real world and you put in a footnote
you know it's
okay anyway uh but uh but yeah i mean i
think that there so this is a big
problem for
that sort of in-principle uh hard
you know hard libertarians you know as
as he puts it in there that like
you know they'll try to move from um and
even he
kind of tries to do this at some point
right you know because he'll he does
you know because he does like using
metaphors with bodily autonomy uh to
ground economic you know liberties
uh at different points in the book but
you know certainly when the hard
libertarian tries to go from bodily
autonomy to
ownership and external property i mean
it always ends up being kind of a weird
mess
uh because because there's just no
obvious principle for uh getting from
one to the other i mean like all the
things that
you know that libertarians can can try
to say you know you you're the first
person to see something
you're the first person to claim
something you mix your labor with
it whatever all of these would be like
okay rules for society to adopt
you know in you know in a circumstance
of
lots of unclaimed land and you know you
need some way to decide how to recognize
freeholding claims
and these would all be like a risk game
you know what i mean you all have your
little pieces and you put them wherever
the map you want and then everybody
starts from there right yeah yeah
exactly so like under those
circumstances
you know like imagining people like you
know pioneers in the western frontier
but without the genocide element like
i have like under those circumstances uh
you know all of these would be okay
systems uh maybe
but uh the idea that any one of them has
some sort of like
principled like deontological status
that this is just like
this is what where you get your natural
rights to property like just just seems
hopelessly
arbitrary and um
which is why to his credit brennan
doesn't really try to do that right he
tries to give a sympathetic hearing to
hard libertarians who do argue that way
but then like at least in those passages
where he's been most precise he says
property is a social convention you know
it has to uh
like they're they're here are all these
reasons why it's a good social
convention to have but it's a social
convention
and a lot of those reasons are just
reasons that would just apply to any
stable uh predictable distributive
system
that uh that you you know it allows
people to make plans because they have
firm expectations about what's going to
happen
that no contracts are going to be on or
all that stuff all that stuff
would be true for like any economic
system with stable well-enforced rules
like that doesn't tell you anything
about why we should have the kind of
property rights that we have under
capitalism
uh and you know and otherwise he's just
giving a consequentialist argument
and when he's giving those
consequentialist arguments it seems like
the way that he likes to do it is by
saying well look
look how much more sure you know uh
having access to money
is a kind of positive liberty blah blah
blah but
um you know poor people are better off
under capitalism you know than under
alternatives so you know so then it's
good to have
capitalist property rights uh but
it's so like it's it's it's so
half-assed i mean it's it's just like
like what is he really comparing that to
he's comparing it to
uh pre-capitalist forms of society you
know feudalism hunter-gatherer side is
whatever
in which case certainly no marxist is
going to disagree with him
uh or uh or he's or he's comparing that
to
um to stalinism i guess but like you
know that
you know i think i would argue that even
there he's severely simplifying
the historical record uh that you know
that like i think the
i think the balance sheets of what's
been good and bad about you know capital
c communist societies is more
is more complicated than what he
suggested uh but
also like okay fair enough
like somebody could say he could say
reasonably all right then you know you
want to say
here's like a kind of like radical
democratic socialism that has never
actually existed
and you know you want me to compare
capitalism to that but that's an unfair
comparison blah blah blah
and we could have a whole argument about
that and how that relates to
you know the crony capitalism stuff matt
was really raising earlier but you did
write a book in response to g.a cohen
which i have not read i should say uh
why not capitalism
response to cohen's why not socialism so
yeah maybe in a future episode we'll go
through that but
no that'd be fun i like that but like i
was just gonna say
um like on a much more basic level like
okay
fair enough so let's just for the sake
of argument uh let's take
like uh let's take uh
alternative more democratic forms of
socialism that have never been tried off
the table
and say that's not even what we're going
to worry about for the sake of
comparison well
the range of existing societies doesn't
just include
uh east germany feudal europe and and
modern capitalism
uh it also includes like advanced social
democracies
uh which uh which certainly uh
score way higher on on most of you know
i would argue on on most of the criteria
he claims to care about
uh than uh than the the uh the far more
laissez-faire you know kind of
capitalism that we have here
it's funny he actually mentions uh he
actually mentions a couple of times like
switzerland
and canada like as examples of countries
that are that
score higher on the freedom index from
like whatever that libertarian think
tank which i thought was kind of funny
because they all have some
form of robust social safety i mean not
like the social democracies of
scandinavia but still
certainly compared to the us exactly
exactly but
this is this also i mean kind of made me
think this discussion
about like the role of consequentialist
reasoning in general in in like
political argumentation and like sort of
to be
to be fair to brennan's sort of like
awkward back and forth between using
like that deontological
sort of hard libertarian reasoning
versus consequentialist social justice
informed reasoning and like
you know i mean i think we see it on uh
like among socialists kind of
analogously in the sense that like you
know if you if you think that
like uh so socialism has to be where the
state or the state or somehow
collectively the means of production are
controlled
but you know there might be a lot of
consequentialist reasons where we think
that
it might be useful to be a market
socialist or something like that and
it's like that right like
when it's convenient it makes sense
because and i mean i don't know this
i don't want to take the discussion off
track but i mean it does i find myself
when i read this
and other times when this question comes
up i remember just being an undergrad
philosophy student right and thinking
about like
well shouldn't like isn't
consequentialism just the thing that
matters like
the most because i feel like if this is
true i mean a couple times reading
brennan's book i mean
rarely was i like thinking convinced by
the
empirical claims he was making about the
consequences
of of markets and and individualism
but like i did think to myself you know
like like as sort of
like what informs my own moral outlook
towards the world like if this was true
i think i would have to support it uh
like
in a few cases anyway right like i don't
have some kind of um ideological or like
or i don't know if the word
deontological would even apply but i
don't have some kind of attachment to
things having to be
government-run like if it's gonna give
me the outcome uh
then i'm gonna support it right and
there's a good reason but like i don't
think that it's gonna give that outcome
so
i just wanted to intervene there in one
second and talk about it about his
history as a bleeding heart
uh so-called libertarian one of the
interesting things about uh bleeding
heart libertarians
uh libertarianism uh is it was very
influenced by the thinking of john rawls
uh who famously near the end of his life
declared himself uh to be either for a
property owning democracy
or some kind of liberal socialism uh
which is what i himself endorse
uh but anyway long story short you know
brandon kind of makes the argument that
actually we could endorse libertarianism
the libertarian approach to property
rights rights
on rawsian principles because he says
look rawls doesn't say we have to be
attached to this or that distributive
order
right what we need to do is be attached
to a distributive order that maximizes
the benefit of the least well off
right sorry any particular empirical
distributed voter and he says
if it turns out empirically that a
libertarian approach to property rights
does make the least well off
better off than any other competitor
then we have good roles in reasons to
adopt it which was an intriguing
argument i don't see him make it that
often any longer i think because i see
because it's so empirically contestable
um i mean you can think about the
scandinavian example uh been brought up
is just
a huge counter argument against that
but at least it was a kind of creative
way of trying to spin things
um in a manner that might be palatable
to some progressives right
i find all of like in general
i find those like libertarian like
country freedom indexes hilarious
because
like libertarians and brennan does this
all the time in the book
we'll treat that as if it's just like
this like really clear or like
uncontroversial like factual starting
point
for more free yeah it's like oh these
are the countries that are objectively
more free than these other countries
it's like
the hell does that mean like you have
like all like
there are zeal like even by libertarian
standards there are a zillion different
factors by which you could
you know evaluate countries and then you
have to come up with a way to weigh them
and like
whatever like you know whatever formula
the cato institute has come up with you
know for for deciding you know which
countries are more free
is extremely opaque uh and
and in some cases just hilarious like
they have uh like like whether
um like whether there are regulations
against like raw milk
is is something that comes up like is
one of the criteria by which they use to
evaluate
rank countries by freedom but like
whether abortion is legal isn't
right so it's uh it's like a it's such a
weird eccentric thing you know like it
is just like taking this like whatever
sort of mixture of 20 factors and
weighted in whatever way makes sense to
you know like whatever intern at the
cato institute is like
has been tasked with crunching these
numbers the idea is like okay well fair
enough so that you know economic freedom
there we go all we have to do is look at
the list especially when
as victor said he keeps on referencing
all these countries that are
much more social democratic than the
united states as being economically
freer it's like
well now i get real confused you know
because like if that's
if all that's compatible with economic
freedom then then
i'm i no longer understand what i
disagree with this guy about
well to be fair to him uh he does
actually point out that despite the fact
that libertarian ideas
are very popular in the united states
the united states
as victor pointed out isn't by not at
all uh close to being
the libertarian paradise uh that many
people wanted to be
and he does you know highlight some of
the examples of this you know one of the
most obvious ones is the fact that
united states land of the free you know
new hampshire's slogan live free or die
uh is also the country with far and away
the highest incarceration rate uh
in the world right uh just
thousands of people per million uh
incarcerated in u.s jails
uh that's certainly not the case uh in
many other countries including some
uh where you expect the incarceration
rate to be far higher uh than in the us
you know the cuba's of the world the
iran's
uh don't want to speak to north korea
since you know i would never trust
anything that comes out of that
government
or china but uh certainly compared to
other um
oecd countries you know the nordic
states france canada et cetera
so it doesn't do really well on those
metrics yeah no that that part is
totally fair but i mean
it's also um and i mean obviously i'm
exaggerating we say i no longer know
what i i mean i know a lot of stuff i
disagree with
about but like it does though seem like
if his conception of economic freedom
isn't violated when you take uh when you
take important
uh aspects of society outside of the
market
and you know pay for them by progressive
taxation and make them free at the point
of service
then like i i do get a little bit
fuzzier about what you know what it what
economic freedom means you know like
like it
and and like certainly all of those
you know canada switzerland never mind
you know norway and sweden and finland
you know like like have
like have done that in spades you know
compared to the states
you know i had a similar experience like
as ben you know i know you like
obviously there's lots of things to
disagree with but there's actually like
a key moment i think when he's talking
about inequality i think it's question
78 when he
when he asks like what do libertarians
think about inequality
and um he kind of says oh so actually i
did
select a quote here he says um classical
and neoclassical liberals hold that
welfarism so welfarism is
i guess prioritizing the welfare of
people and then he talks about
sufficientarianism which is like
the idea that you have to make sure
everyone has like the sufficient means
to be free
like sufficient like material resources
and then prioritarianism right which is
like we should prioritize the worst off
so he kind of like
bundles all three of these views and he
says that they capture the moral force
of egalitarianism which is what he
thinks
is like kind of motivating the left um
and then he says if welfarist
sufficientarian or and prioritarian
goals have been met
from the standpoint of social justice
egalitarianism has
no remaining attraction right so he says
and then he says
neoclassical liberals agree that a fair
and just society
gives everyone a stake in that society a
just society has institutions that
ensure as much as possible that everyone
has the resources needed
to be a free person still they say the
goal of a society is to make
everyone well off not to make them equal
right so like to make everyone well off
but not necessarily equal
and i mean i mean reading that again i
kind of had this this sensation of being
like well i guess like that's
like i'm not going to disagree that i
want that too but but i guess the
question obviously is like empirically
are
is the is is that actually going to be
achievable from the things he wants but
it is interesting that he kind of is
trying to set up his argument to be
look if i meet all these things then
like your egalitarian concern goes away
like that's kind of like the way he's
trying to structure it which is key i
think to the
argument and here i think we need to be
careful right uh i mean
uh nozick and anarchy state utopia has a
critique of egalitarianism which i think
is
kind of a caricature of what a lot of us
actually want
but unless it's quite popular uh and he
runs look you know
uh if you're really committed to
substantive equality uh or you know the
dreaded
pedersonian equality of outcome right uh
does that mean you know if you have
people running a race and some people
have natural abilities that
exceed those of others that you should
put weights in their shoes or handicap
them in some way
uh if somebody is more handsome than
other people
it's handsome man thought experiment
which i didn't think was funny actually
uh should you try to make him less
attractive uh
so that he doesn't out-compete uh other
people in the sexual marketplace
purely through morally arbitrary
advantages that have to do with genetics
for which he can take no credit right
and he says obviously we would never
want to do
any of these things uh ergo what we
shouldn't be trying to aspire to
is equality along any or most metrics
right it's kind of like the incredible
uh
problem if anybody's seen that movie uh
you know at some point the villain in
the movie says you know
if everyone is special then nobody will
be you know that's the kind of damning
world that he paints for us right
uh and in responding to that uh i
typically say look you know
it's i can't think of any serious
egalitarian
and i'm like ben will always say i'm
sure if we scour the internet
you know there'll be somebody there who
says you know we must be equal equal in
every single respect
you know bar none uh but you know
serious egalitarians who will say we
need to be equal along
every single metric right uh virtually
everybody i can think of recognizes that
there'll be substantial differences in
personal
property uh in a socialist society uh
that people's natural abilities
will differ in some important respects
and that might actually be a good thing
if they develop them and they can be
beneficial to the rest of society
and of course people will differ in
terms of their personal virtue right uh
try though i might i can't think of even
the most dystopian scenario uh
where sci-fi authors come up with a way
of making good people
evil uh or evil people good right a lot
of that has to do with
individual choices personal
characteristics social environments
that go beyond even just economics etc
etc so there will be inequalities
right in the kind of socialist society
that i would want
uh and i imagine ben would want uh the
question is you know
how far should we allow economic
inequalities
uh that relate to substantial power
inequities uh to stand
uh and there i think we would want to be
a lot more scrupulous uh than
renin is because i think allowing
substantial inequities
in economic power that translates into
political power
uh isn't just wrong morally but
fundamentally actually poses serious
existential problems
to liberal society because the emergence
of things like crony capitalism
and many of the other things that we've
talked about i'm not sure if you guys
agree but i'm just going to put that
forward
as a kind of argument yeah yeah i i
think so
uh i mean i i do think there are
you know arguments for
taking equality seriously
like as a as like a default
uh that you know that um that i i'm not
convinced that brennan is adequately
uh you know is adequately grappling with
right you know that like that i i think
even in some of his
arguments where again i'd point to you
know the ways that
he addresses or doesn't quite address
questions about racial justice as
a place where he seems to get like
slightly embarrassed at certain points
by where libertarian principles would
lead him
you know if uh if taken like
sufficiently seriously
um you know both in uh
his you know his willingness to to root
to
outlaw private sector you know just
discrimination uh for you know for
consequentialist reasons and also
in the places where he sort of says well
okay in a quote distributive inequality
between black people and white people in
the united states
didn't really come out come about you
know in an immaculate way
and so maybe we could do something or
other to correct it
i'm not quite sure what next section uh
and
uh and in in those in that second place
in particular it seems to me that he is
kind of granting that like
inequality might be a little bit
troubling um
in itself that like okay maybe racial
inequality would be okay if it just sort
of happened that way
right but like since it didn't it's not
but
presumably he wouldn't go the other way
around he wouldn't say well if we just
happened
if um you know let's say that if we'd
let the free market chips fall where we
may for whatever reason there'd be a
little bit more racial inequality just
due to whatever weird historical
circumstances
uh therefore it's not okay that we have
greater equality right
the way he would when it's the other way
around so uh
i think in that passage it seems to me
that like
even he feels a little bit of a pull of
of egalitarianism
but i generally i generally agree with
that right like i mean i think that
nobody's really
um i mean it's even beyond the sort of
harrison bergeron examples about you
know about the uh you know
uh like inequality and looks or
inequality
and you know singing ability and you
know and all that stuff
uh none of which is stuff that you know
really for the most part you know like
like
uh left us big you know object too much
like even on the sort of stricter
like questions of economic equality uh i
don't know who these people are really
who
who think that they we have to have like
perfect uh
economic equality um you know i mean
again scour the internet you'll find
someone i'm sure yes yeah absolutely
right i mean cicero said there's no
position so
absurd that some philosopher doesn't
defend it and you know for sure there's
no position so absurd that someone in
reddit doesn't defend it you know like
you will be able to find
someone for everything but uh but by and
large right
uh do social democrats think that no
certainly not right do like new deal
great society left liberals think that
no certainly not
uh do marxists think that well mark
certainly didn't
uh you know read read critique of the
gotham program you know he he thought
that in a
uh early stage of a socialist society
you would need some material uh
inequality for the sake of incentives
that you know if you some people
chose to work harder you know or longer
hours than others you know you should
you should
give them more material rewards to
incentivize that and he thought in a
more advanced social society
uh where you had material super
abundance then the whole issue of
distributive equality would
sort of be moot because everybody could
could take what they want and whatever
you think about that
um like just bracketing any question
about how realistic or well thought out
any of that is like
that's certainly not a vision of
absolute egalitarianism in either half
uh and in the um and
and certainly people who have like more
sort of elaborate schemes of like how
market socialism or participatory
economics or whatever
certainly none of those people are
envisioning that we have exact perfect
in a distributive inequality the issue
is
are there reasons to object to it to
like extreme inequalities are are there
reasons to think
okay um yeah some people have a little
bit more than others and whatnot and
there might be good reasons to to have
that but like
you know uh have like the sort of
inequalities so extreme
that they would lead to some people
agreeing to just stand your capitalist
labor contracts
where they gave away their voice and
their vote in the operation in exchange
for having any kind of job at all
right like the sort of thing that which
by the way right now
slight side note but give me like 30
seconds on this i do love
uh that as we are recording this a super
pervasive right wing talking point
uh is in the united states is oh my god
it's terrible that with these universal
income payments because of covid
uh that uh that people you know we can't
find anybody to flip burgers anymore
uh that uh like like every you know
all of these like you know biz like
empirically it's a little dubious like
how much truth there is to that but like
there are certainly a lot of business
owners and a lot of right-wing
politicians who
that's their stated belief that it's a
big problem finding enough people to
flip burgers you know because of
the ui payments and it's like that just
really seems like a mask off thing you
know because it's like okay well
which is it right like are you actually
gonna claim that people are working
these jobs with their own free will
uh or or are you kind of admitting that
you need the whip of destitution to get
people to agree to work under these
circumstances
which it really seems like they're
admitted in these cases
uh and in fact you know yeah i mean like
whether whether it's true or not that
there is that that much of a labor
shortage uh
you know their stated explanation of it
assumes that you need the whip of
destitution to get people to agree
to work at mcdonald's or walmart or
wherever but uh but also
so like yeah having so much inequality
that you get that
the workplaces problem having so much
inequality you get inequality and
political influence is a problem having
so much inequality
that you end up you know uh having um
that uh that you end up having people
some people just have much worse life
outcomes
uh is uh is is a problem in itself
which you know like you you know go back
to to the race metaphor it's like okay
if all you're doing is hobbling the
person at the front and you're not doing
anything to help people in the back sure
maybe
you know that would be silly right but
uh but
of course the whole issue is that uh
is that there are all these reasons to
to think that the two are not unrelated
you know that uh
even if you agree with some of like
brennan's economic arguments and think
that like bad incentives are created
you know that do uh you know that like
so maybe you're
you know maybe the effect of some of the
stuff is to do more hoplite at the front
than helping people to back
undeniably you are helping people at the
back you know when you do
you know when you do redistribution uh
so
uh so yeah i mean like maybe this goes
to victor's point about you know
consequentialism
you know even though i mean i'm
certainly not a um
i'm certainly not willing to go all the
way to pure consequentialism you know
in moral political philosophy i mean i
think we could
you know i'm i i think um you know you
could come up with some scenario where
you know you have a teensy tiny little
slave class that's you know that's
subordinate you know to everybody else
and the doctors to slice up their
patients and redistribute their organs
exactly right so like for all of those
reasons i wouldn't go all the way to
pure consequentialism but like also
i do kind of have the reaction that
victor is expressing earlier to a lot of
that stuff which is like
okay sure yeah do sufficientarianism and
welfarism and prior
prioritism or whatever it is like
prioritarianism uh
like maybe when you put those three
together they do capture most of the
reasons
to care about equality but also i think
as an empirical matter that
if you take those three things really
seriously then you
you can't have too much economic
inequality or it's going to mess with
all three of them
yeah i totally i totally agree with that
and i mean to answer to matt's earlier
point like i i do think that
the point of brennan bringing up those
different isms the prioritarianism right
is to say that like you know obviously
he's not gonna
like people like most leftists don't
want like perfect equality um right
there there's like there's like you know
you want to make sure everyone has
sufficient means and
and whatever but you know uh
sort of reading this book and and this
discussion is also reminding me of
matt and i did a podcast a while ago
where we looked at uh
uh wolf's anarchism the in defensive
anarchism book i'm not sure if you've
ever read it ben but um
but like i mean the the the reasoning in
that like
the reaction i had to that book it was
like a very like fixated on this like
very strict definition of freedom like
like a kind of deontological obsession
with freedom
and i mean obviously brennan's hedging
uh here a lot more
but you know it does it does when i
think about like
the tendency i suppose in political
philosophy to get too fixated on one
thing right i guess the left you could
accuse them of sometimes in bad versions
getting too fixated on equality
yeah they're getting too fixated on
equality and then i don't know
libertarians too fixated on freedom and
you know and i think back to just why i
got interested in political philosophy
and political theory
which is just thinking about like those
deep questions about what is the good
life and like what are we what's the
point of us living together and
organizing our society it's like what
are we actually after
and it's like freedom to me it's like is
that like that's not even
um like it's good for something right
like freedom is good to do something to
like
and so but then when you start to just
get to you almost reify
like it seems like some of these
libertarian arguments are like reifying
freedom as if it's like this
this intrinsically important good but
like really i don't know as a
as a as a leftist with with sort of um
consequentialist concerns about the good
life about living the good life it's
like i'm only interested in the freedom
that's gonna get that's gonna enable me
to do something that's that's
related to like the good life i suppose
yeah
and and i mean like i don't know i mean
maybe i think
i might have slightly different
intuitions about this like i think that
um whether freedom is sort of
at the um like at the floor
as we go down to to our list of concerns
whether it's all the way back down there
or not right like it's certainly
uh and i mean i think that's an
interesting question like how much of
its instrumental
which you know a lot of brennan's
arguments are anyway right and and how
much of it
is uh you know that we value in itself
and i think i am inclined to
you know think that we that we do value
in itself to some extent you know
although also it's incredibly ambiguous
right there are different kinds of
freedom you know but
um but i i would feel really remiss if
we ended the discussion with without
like noting
that um you know that like one of my
biggest criticisms
of the book is that you know is that
brennan uh
kind of takes it for granted throughout
uh that freedom or at least negative
freedom you know he
you know when he's talking about
positive freedom he he does understand
that you know like he has to make like
slightly more complicated
consequentialist arguments and
for all the reasons we've talked about
him not sold on those arguments but put
that to one side right he also seems to
assume
that uh negative freedom uh is like
unambiguously associated with
libertarian you know policies
uh and and i i'd really hate for us to
have this whole discussion without
pushing back against that at least a
little bit you know since
uh i mean for one thing um you know the
classical marxist objection to
capitalist employment contracts
uh is is that they they are uh coercive
uh that they uh that people you know
that given
uh you know wildly unequal bargaining
power
uh you know that that you don't really
have
um you know that you're not really
making a totally uncoerced you know free
decision to agree to these arrangements
uh and and so that's that's one thing
but then another thing is just that like
he keeps talking like he does a very
typical libertarian thing throughout
this book where he just constantly talks
about
force and violence and coercion in this
way that suggests
that uh that you know that force and
violence and coercion
like more libertarian more economically
libertarian means less force of violence
and coercion
and and i think that should really be
questioned in a lot of ways right like
one of them
is the way that prudhon was uh was
talking about you know
when he said the property is theft which
is um
you know i think about a lot now you
know because because you know
my wife and i've been riding out the
pandemic and uh you know hodon lake
michigan which as the name suggests you
know is is a
is a town that's that's like right next
to a lake but like
man good luck to you if you uh if you
want to like find a place to like
actually walk into the lake
you know without without trespassing on
someone's property you know you have to
drive a long time
you know to uh to get to the one tiny
little bit of public you know
of public beach where the water's like a
foot deep you know that's uh
uh so by definition property
is about asserting at least the threat
of force
to stop people from using something like
like that's that's that's what property
is you know that you're asserting a
right to exclusively
uh to exclusively use something and if
you're not gonna enforce it it's not
worth very much
uh so uh you know certainly proper i
mean what do property rights mean when
it comes to like squatters and
unoccupied buildings presumably it means
using
coercion you know whether whether pro
you know whether
public coercion for the police or
private security or whatever
to uh to to enforce you know to enforce
property rights
uh and sophisticated libertarians like
understand this and
and they and they will when you press
them be very careful about it they won't
say okay no no we're not really
talking about violence exactly right as
what we're objecting to we're not
talking
about you know force or coercion in the
ordinary
sense of that term which is like you
know pointing a gun at someone
you know as as as a use of force or you
know saying you know if you don't do
what i say i'll call
some state authorities to come and force
enforce it what they're really talking
about
is aggression uh which uh which when but
then when they get around to telling you
what that means
as matt brunick famously points out it
gets very circular very quickly you know
because
whether something counts as aggression
or not ultimately boils down to whether
you have a legitimate property claim or
not
and at that point we're just arguing
about what the distribution of resources
should be which is like well
if that's what we're arguing about like
we should have just started there and
not
gone down this rabbit hole of what you
know of force and violence and coercion
yeah i absolutely agree uh and i gotta
end with this point and then
victor can have the last word uh or
maybe ben if you wanna respond to both
of things uh but i'm just gonna say that
um there are two types of libertarians
that i encounter
uh online uh there's the good
sophisticated libertarian and then
there's the anti-woke libertarian
uh and what i've noticed about the
anti-woke libertarian is
they're not actually all that
libertarian right uh generally speaking
they tend to
associate with libertarianism or
classical liberalism typically for a
while
uh this is the stephan molyneux type
crowd and i'd also throw in ludwig von
mises
and anne ryan is more sophisticated but
not by much uh kind
of expositors of this position uh and
what you find if you actually delve into
their arguments is that
they aren't actually committed very
deeply to even the classical liberal
liberties
uh what they're committed to is this
idea that people need to be sorted
hierarchically
in terms of superior and inferior and
the reason they
like the market is they see the market
as being able to accomplish this
but if you start to see things and this
is what you're starting to see with the
republicans right now
like woke capitalism for example what's
quite striking
is a lot of these libertarians will very
quickly change their gear
a little bit and start talking about why
we need the state to actually undertake
aggressive action in order to recreate
the hierarchy that they feel is
appropriate
so if not capitalism then it needs to be
something else okay
and a lot of people i see online who
kind of ascribe to libertarianism seem
to hold these beliefs
i don't think they're really legit what
i do like about this book is brandon
does seem to me to at least be a
principled libertarian right
uh he's willing to bite the bullet and
says we have this deontological
commitment
uh to liberty uh a certain kind of
radical equality and property rights
uh and we need to stand by it not no
matter what because this he doesn't
include some qualifications but pretty
consistently
right that includes things like no
social restrictions on those kinds of
actions
open borders uh not going to war and
i'll give them a lot of credit for that
what i don't like about this book is
again and i think
ben talked about this the prioritization
of certain kinds of freedom
over others and with paul graham and
victor i agree that
we shouldn't just prioritize freedom i
think there are other things that we
have reason to value
but even if we are just going to
prioritize freedom i think it's
important to ask
what that means and i think
libertarianism does a good job of
accounting for our desire for
negative liberty uh and to a certain
extent our desire for positive liberty
but what it really doesn't care very
much about and brandon is just a
spectacular example of that
is social liberty uh or civic freedom as
it's sometimes called right the right to
be
governed uh by a set of laws and
institutions
that i myself have a say in right uh and
this of course is a conception of
liberty that goes back to the ancient
greeks
and it's something that i can't think of
any serious libertarian thinker who
actually prioritizes it precisely
because they know circa banned that if
we have the option
of trying to decide what kind of
institutional arrangements we truly
desire
we might not actually choose to have a
organization of property rights and
entitlements
that conforms to what libertarians wish
and where this potential starts to arise
you'll see them very quickly start to
turn against democracy
and civic freedom and i say that because
of course that's the title of brennan's
most famous book right against democracy
where he makes this argument abundantly
clear right that
we do not need to have civic freedom uh
if that's going to challenge my
conception of the kinds of freedom
that i feel we have reason to prioritize
uh
yeah absolutely so for our listeners
you can read this book and the argument
is put forward there i think for it's
put forward a lot more elaboration
and against democracy but what's worth
noting about it even in that book is
that he doesn't really have a good
answer to this issue of civic freedom
or social freedom however you want to
call it uh he basically just says well
participating in government uh it's such
a small freedom you have such a little
say
voting doesn't really matter all that
much and most people don't vote anyway
so there's no real reason we should
prioritize it all that much
to which i respond no that actually goes
to demonstrate how impoverished a lot of
our democratic institutions are
and it's why we need to make sure that
civic freedom
gets a big comeback uh both at the state
level and also preferably in the
workplace
also by the way i mean he he cares
passionately
about freedom to own the means of
production
and uh a hell of a lot fewer people do
that than vote
yeah that's right that's for sure both
of them yeah that's right he actually
said he also said i think he's
calls like a concern with civic freedom
or democracy i think he calls it like
romantic
or something he's like it's a romantic
thing that like i don't see any
intrinsic
good in in like expressing your
democratic will but i did want to end
quickly just to kind of emphasize what i
think is
like my takeaway or at least an
important takeaway is like the tension
as we've been talking about it between
his
kind of like deontological attachment to
freedom but then also his
commitment to social justice and i think
like you know if he's true to his word i
think because as i read earlier from
question 78 right he says that just
society has institutions that ensure as
much as possible that everyone has the
resources needed
to be a free person so like he kind of
commits himself to this he says
that's the view he ascribes to
neoclassical liberals what he
says he is um and then i guess it just
i mean it would be interesting to see
whether he was if he was confronted with
empirical evidence to show that like the
libertarian
uh society would not give uh would not
create those
institutions um then that would i guess
reveal
like to what extent he's actually more
uh
more of the engine of his view is from
the deontological
libertarian view or whether it's from
this kind of more consequentialist
concern with social justice
um and you know i would say like i mean
for myself as a leftist like
i really feel like a lot of my my
motivation comes from
these empirical questions about what's
actually going to create these
institutions that i i mean i agree with
the way he phrases it even that is gonna
make sure everyone can exercise
their freedom in a meaningful way and of
course i would also say that that should
include civic freedom and so i would
agree with matt
um so you know i would i would i i would
probably if i saw evidence that like i
don't know minimum wage or whatever and
he i know he has a chapter
about or talks about it briefly actually
created bad outcomes i mean i would
change my position on that so it would
be interesting to know whether he would
actually change his position if he was
confronted with
such uh analogous evidence well
we'll leave that as an open question
since brendan's not that old so i'm sure
we'll be seeing a lot more of them
over the years um so anyway for our
listeners at the pill pod
uh who are interested again you can
check out brennan's book
libertarianism what everyone needs to
know honestly it's only
i think like 150 short pages uh you
could get through it in an afternoon or
two just pour yourself a big pot of
coffee
not badly written uh we have a lot of
problems with it as you've heard
uh but you know readable book okay uh
stefan mullen you you should read it
because it's um
all you you know libertarian bros out
there take a look at this uh if you want
some of the real deal uh you might
decide to convert pretty [ __ ] quickly
um anyway also thanks a lot for coming
on the show again ben
it's always great to have you and i'm
sure we'll be seeing you again in the
future
sounds good